maybe later you're gonna be at a protest  and someone's gonna have a poster that  says they buried us but they didn't know  we were seeds that's poetry you might be  in your U.S history class and your  teacher may play a video of Martin  Luther King Jr saying we'll be able to  Hew out of this mountain of Despair a  stone of hope that's poetry or maybe  even here in New York City you're gonna  go visit the Statue of Liberty where  there's a sonnet that declares As  Americans give us you're tired you're  poor your huddled masses yearning to be  free so you see when someone asks me to  write a poem that's not political what  they're really asking me is to not ask  charged and challenging questions in my  poetic work and that does not work  because poetry is always at the pulse of  the most dangerous and the most daring  questions that a nation or a world might  face